bonjour à vous tous chez Brut et
j'espère qu'ensemble nous pourrons rendre le monde
meilleur alors s'il vous plaît rejoignez-nous et faites
votre part la situation de la faune dans le
monde est affreuse le braconnage se
poursuit sans relâche avec les éléphants d'Afrique et les
rhinocéros et les pingouins  dans le monde
et les tigres en Asie et il y a la
chasse au trophée où les gens vont tirer sur de
beaux animaux pour le plaisir et ils pensent que
l'argent ira aux
efforts de conservation, mais en fait, la majeure
partie va dans les poches des fonctionnaires corrompus
J'ai eu le privilège de  passer des jours et des
semaines dans la forêt tropicale et lorsque vous êtes dans
la forêt tropicale, vous
comprenez comment toutes les formes de vie sont
interconnectées et chaque petite espèce
peut sembler insignifiante, mais elle a un rôle
à jouer dans cette grande tapisserie de la vie
et c'est comprendre  l'
interdépendance de tous les êtres vivants
de tous les problèmes de tous les peuples qui
font comprendre à quel point
il est désespérément important que nous fassions tous notre part,
même si c'est sa  n'ayant qu'une
petite espèce qui va être
importante
j'ai cinq raisons d'espérer tout d'
abord les jeunes une fois qu'ils ont
compris les problèmes et que nous leur donnons les moyens
d'agir ils sont en
train de changer le monde en ce moment même le cerveau humain que
nous avons  un intellect extraordinaire
et bien que nous ne l'ayons pas utilisé très
judicieusement maintenant, les gens proposent des
idées pour guérir certains des dommages que
nous avons infligés à l'énergie verte propre, par
exemple le troisième est la résilience des
lieux naturels que nous avons détruits donnent
leur temps et un peu d'aide parfois
et la nature restaurera à nouveau un
habitat et les animaux au bord de l'
extinction peuvent avoir une autre chance le
quatrième est les médias sociaux mais la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité, nous pouvons rassembler des
gens du
monde entier
pour  élèvent la voix pour protester contre le
changement climatique l'utilisation du charbon ce genre
de chose et enfin l'
esprit humain indomptable les gens qui s'attaquent à ce qui
semble impossible et n'abandonneront pas et
si souvent réussir vous savez que le gros
problème est que plus de gens sont conscients
des problèmes que nous avons créés mais ils se sentent
impuissants et sans espoir et qu'il n'y a
rien qu'ils puissent faire alors ils abandonnent et perdent
espoir Je veux dire aux gens que
chacun de nous est  Il est important que chacun
d'entre nous ait un rôle à jouer même si nous
ne savons pas exactement ce que c'est, mais surtout,
chacun d'entre nous
a un impact sur la planète
chaque jour et nous avons le choix du
type de différence.  allons-nous faire
aujourd'hui
[Musique]